ready. Good afternoon. Welcome to Preventive Medicine Grand Rounds for November 3, 2021.
I'm Antonio Neri from the Division of Scientific Education and Professional Development. The
Preventive Medicine Grand Rounds is sponsored by the CDC Preventive Medicine Residency and Fellowship,
as well as the Health Resources and Services Administration Bureau of Health Workforce.
The PMRF at CDC provides 12- and 24-month full-time longitudinal service learning
opportunities with senior public and population health leaders for physicians, veterinarians,
and nurses who have completed the CDC Epidemic Intelligence Service Program or have equivalent
public health experience. We use Zoom, as you can see, for the audio and presentation,
and the question and answer box to pose questions. Note that you can pose questions
via the question box at any point during the lecture, and those speakers will answer them
at their discretion. Note that your name may be associated with the question you pose. If
you do not wish your name to be associated with the question, then please check the
submit anonymously box on your question. Continuing education credits are available
for the live course for up to one month after the presentation date, and for the recorded version,
up to two years from the date of presentation through the CDC Training and Continuing Education
Online Portal. The course code to access these ground rounds is all-capital letters, C-D-C-P-M-R-F.
Again, all capitals, C-D-C-P-M-R-F. If you have questions, please contact myself, Antonio Neri,
or email the program at prevmed.cdc.gov. Please remember that the views presented by the speaker
are theirs alone and do not represent CDC, the Department of Health and Human Services,
or the U.S. Government. Before we start our grand rounds, we'll take our usual moment of silence
for our friends, family, and colleagues who have suffered from COVID or even passed away.
Okay. Today's grand rounds will be entitled, Introduction to Tribal Public Health Infrastructure
and CDC by Captain Karen Heard, who is with the Centers for Disease Control Center for State,
Local, Tribal, and Territorial Support. Captain Heard, the floor is yours. Take it away.
Good afternoon, and thank you for allowing me the time to share with you this presentation about
tribal public health infrastructure and CDC. So, as was shared, I am Captain Karen Heard,
and I'm a citizen of the Choctaw Nation of Oklahoma, and I'm coming to you today from
the Choctaw Reservation in Oklahoma. Next slide, please.
The learning objectives for today's presentation include develop more awareness and knowledge of
the diversity of American Indian Alaskan Native populations, identify historical laws that greatly
impact American Indian Alaskan Native populations, understand how AIAN populations are unique to
public health, develop awareness of partners that contribute to AIAN public health, understand how
CDC supports tribal public health infrastructure, and learn about CDC Office of Tribal Affairs and
Strategic Alliances and their collaborations and work with American Indian Alaskan Native populations.
Next slide, please.
So, as an introduction for my office, the Office of Tribal Affairs and Strategic Alliances,
or OTASA, we reside within CDC's Center for State, Tribal, Local, and Territorial Support,
or CSTLTS. CSTLTS works to improve community health outcomes by strengthening state,
tribal, local, and territorial health agencies. Next slide, please.
This organizational chart highlights CSTLTS leadership. In the middle of the chart,
you see our Director, Dr. Jose Montero, and the Acting Deputy Director, Dr. Andrea Young.
You also see the OTASA office that I direct depicted on the left. Next slide, please.
OTASA's mission is to affirm the government-to-government relationship
between CDC and American Indian and Alaskan Native tribal nations by advancing connections,
providing expertise, and increasing resources to improve tribal communities' public health.
Next slide, please.
OTASA works closely with American Indian and Alaskan Native communities to coordinate activities,
provide expertise, technical assistance, and resources. As CDC's principal point of contact
for American Indian and Alaskan Native tribal nations and tribal-serving organizations,
OTASA works to connect tribal nations, tribal-serving organizations, and other stakeholders
to CDC and the Agency for Toxic Substances Disease Registry, or ATSDR, programs. We ensure that
American Indian and Alaskan Native communities receive public health services that keep them
safe and healthy, and we provide and facilitate funding for building and improving cross-cutting
tribal public health infrastructure. Next slide, please.
Before we discuss public health infrastructure, it's important to first note the vast diversity
of American Indian and Alaskan Native communities. There are currently 574 federally recognized
tribal nations across the United States. Each tribal nation is unique in their history,
cultural practices, and traditions. Moreover, tribal nations range in capacity of public health
workforce as well as the tribal public health departments and population size of the tribal
nations themselves. Tribal nations can range in size from some California rancherias of less than
one acre to the Navajo Nation at more than 17 million acres. Tribal sovereignty refers to the
rights of American Indian and Alaskan Natives to govern themselves. Each tribal nation also differs
in their own laws and policies. As sovereign nations, the federal government has a government
to government relationship with each tribal nation to uphold. Next slide, please.
When understanding public health infrastructure for American Indian and Alaskan Native populations,
it is important to first understand a few key historical federal Indian laws that greatly
impact tribal nations and American Indian Alaskan Native populations. Next slide, please.
We will start with the Federal Indian Removal Act of 1830. This federal policy authorized President
Jackson the right to make land exchanges by forcibly removing the five tribes Cherokee,
Muskogee Creek, Chickasaw, Mai Tribe, Choctaw, and Seminole from their ancestral lands against
their will. Over the next several decades, more than 40 tribes were removed to Indian country,
an area that now comprises the state of Oklahoma. President Jackson rationalized the removal program
as a benevolent effort that gave American Indians one last chance to assimilate and
give up their culture. And President Andrews Jackson addressed to Congress, he told lawmakers,
surrounded by our settlements, these Indians have neither the intelligence, the industry,
the moral habits, nor the desire of improvement, which are essential to any favorable change in
their condition. Established in the midst of another and superior race and without appreciating
the causes of their inferiority or seeking to control them, they must necessarily yield to the
force of circumstances and ere long disappear. The Treaty of Dancing Rabbit Creek, which was
proclaimed on February 24, 1831, between the Choctaw and the United States, is the treaty
that brought my family to Oklahoma, where I live today. About 17,000 Choctaws started the journey
from Mississippi to Oklahoma, and it's estimated that nearly a third died along the way from
starvation, exposure, and disease. Today, though, we claim over 200,000 Choctaw Nation citizens.
I wanted to just take a chance and share briefly a personal experience that I have related to the
removal route and the journey. So in June of 2012, I had the honor of participating with a small group
from the University of Washington's Indigenous Wellness Research Institute and the Choctaw Nation
of Oklahoma, re-walking the historical Trail of Tears. The project was named Jopali, and in the
Choctaw language, Jopali means to walk slowly and softly. The goal of the walk as a pilot project
was to connect culturally with the space to discuss and pledge to the health of future Choctaw
generations. We began and ended the day with cultural teachings and really reflected on our
diet and exercise. Prior to this walk, I had gained some weight and wasn't in great shape, so I was
getting kind of in touch with my physical health, and it also presented an opportunity for
participants to make meaningful health changes, and I was able to do that. So I was able to
make meaningful health changes in our own lives. So the removal route is about 500 miles, and so
as we planned for the walk, we had to do a lot of research around the history of the trails,
and that meant that we learned some about our own family's path to Oklahoma.
And I just wanted to share an experience that I had personally during this time. There was a
part in the path that's close to present-day Washington State Park, and that's a recreated
kind of historical site in Arkansas of a town that was there previously, and my family had come
through this area, and for those of you that aren't familiar with Arkansas, there's several
areas that can become very boggy and hard to get through, and my family had come up on this site
and had to wade through water that was kind of up to our shoulders, and a lot of people became
sickened during this time, and even some of the little ones died across this, and so when they
came out of this area, there was a little town, and this town would not allow them to stay,
and so they had to keep walking in a town close to present-day Washington State Park,
allowed them to stay, and fed them, and gave them comfort. And when we re-walked the walk
at this time, I became pretty overwhelmed putting my feet in the soil kind of of my ancestors,
and we were all very tired and worn down at this park at this point in time, and some archaeologists
that were staying at Washington State Park when we walked through invited us to stay the night
fed us a meal and gave us comfort during this time, and it really brought home to me
the meaning of this trail and the sacrifice that our ancestors made for us to keep our tribal
sovereignty and make a new home in Oklahoma. So I just wanted to share that because I think
these stories kind of bring them that, make these experiences more real and bring deeper
understanding. Let's go ahead and go to the next slide please.
So in 1851, the U.S. Congress passes the Indian Appropriations Act, creating the reservation
system to move western tribes onto reservations. The men who created the reservation system believe
that American Indians could be confined to one particular geographical place reserved for them,
they could become civilized and assimilated into American life and transformed into good Christian
farmers. The reservations were established to make sure the remaining tribes converted to
Christianity and became Americanized. Within reservation borders, American Indians were not
allowed to leave except by permission. Those who left were arrested and severely punished.
The federal policies were enforced by Indian agents which suppressed tribal culture and
traditional activities. Treaties were the primary method for creating reservations,
but Congress suspended formal treaty development in 1871. Therefore, executive orders, congressional
acts, or any legal combination recognized by the federal government were used to establish
federal reservations. Go ahead and go to the next slide please.
The General Allotment Act of 1887 is also known as the Dawes Act of 1887. This policy had a
disastrous effect on many tribes. This federal policy was designed to detribalize the American
Indian by destroying the idea of communal land ownership on the reservations. The provisions of
the General Allotment Act include the allotments were held in trust by the U.S. government for 25
years. Eligible American Indians had four years to select their land, but afterwards the selection
would be made for them by the Secretary of the Interior. U.S. citizenship would be confirmed
upon American Indians who abandoned their tribes and adopted the habit of civilized life.
Lastly, all land not allotted were averted to the control of the federal government and can be sold.
Consequently, land owned by American Indians decreased from 138 million acres in 1887
to only 48 million acres in 1934. This act also established the Dawes Roll, which my tribe,
the Choctaw Nation, still uses for descendancy and tribal membership. My great-great-grandmother,
Matilda Harrell, and her son, my great-grandfather, James Harrell, were the original enrollees for my
family. Go ahead and go to the next slide, please. The Indian Reorganization Act of 1934,
also known as the Wheeler-Howard Act, was signed by President Roosevelt on June 18,
1934. This law allows tribes to establish formal governments within limited powers
and allows the formation of corporations to manage tribal resources. So the Indian Reorganization
Act offered federal subsidies to tribes that adopted constitutions like that of the United
States and replaced their government with city council-style governments. Also, American Indians
were given the right to establish a credit system and it granted certain rights of home
rule to American Indians. It provided some vocational education. Also, employment of
American Indian in the Bureau of Indian Affairs was also increased. This act served to give
American Indians a chance at a new deal, quotation marks that ran parallel to many other programs.
Go ahead and go to the next slide, please. In 1953, Congress passes a resolution beginning
federal policy of termination. The image above shows a relocation brochure distributed to
American Indians in the 1950s. A companion policy of relocation moves Indians off reservations and
into urban areas. Through these policies, the BIA planned to move thousands of American Indian
people to cities and urban jobs. The goal really was to absorb American Indians into mainstream society.
Go ahead and go to the next slide, please.
So from some of the key federal Indian laws that we've just discussed,
I would like to now transition in to discuss social determinants of health and how American
Indian Alaskan Native populations might uniquely experience social determinants of health.
Go to the next slide, please.
Historical trauma is the intergenerational collective experience of complex trauma
that was inflicted on a group of people who share a specific group identity or affiliations
such as nationality, religious affiliation, or ethnicity. As discussed earlier, the forced removal
from Native lands because of government policy is one example of historical trauma. Another example
experienced widely across American Indian Alaskan Native population is government policies sending
children to boarding schools, which prohibited speaking Native languages or practicing their
individual spirituality. These policies have caused tremendous impact across multiple generations,
such as loss of Native languages, cultural practices, and loss of Native foods as a result
of loss of land. On November 26, 2019, the President signed Executive Order 13898, forming the
Task Force on Missing and Murdered American Indian Alaskan Natives, also recognized as Operation Lady
Justice. The OLAJ Task Force aims to enhance the criminal justice system and address the legitimate
concerns of American Indian Alaskan Native communities regarding missing and murdered people,
specifically missing and murdered Indigenous women and girls. So this task force is a multi-agency
effort that will allow top federal officials to engage, coordinate, and work with tribal governments
on developing strategies to address the crisis by looking at means to collect and manage data
across jurisdictions, establish protocols for new and unsolved cases, establishing multi-jurisdictional
cold case teams, improving response to investigative challenges, and providing clarity on roles,
authorities, and jurisdiction. For CDC, Laura Coller and Dr. Delight Satter represent CDC
on this OLAJ Task Force. Additionally, as we look at social determinants of health,
we see that multi-generational housing is an important consideration when developing
strategies for public health programs. Many American and Alaskan Native populations reside
within multiple generations with youth and elders in the same home. So this has really come to light
when we look at addressing quarantining related to COVID-19 and specific strategies to
protect the elders in the home. Access is another important consideration for Native populations.
Access to food and health care can be difficult due to geographical location alone for some.
In wintertime, especially, some roads can be inaccessible or at times of flooding.
Also, specifically for health care access, the rurality of American and Alaskan Native
communities can cause a provider shortage. Additionally, compared to white residents,
rural AIAN populations were disproportionately concentrated in rural counties that are above
the median for a proportion of their population that lacks health insurance. Additionally,
food insecurity is strongly correlated with malnutrition and underweight as well as obesity
and type 2 diabetes. Sometimes access to vegetables and fruit intake can decline significantly as food
insecurity increases, which can contribute to excess cancer and cardiovascular risk.
Go ahead and go to the next slide, please.
So the American Indian and Alaskan Native people have long experienced lower health status when
compared with other Americans. Lower life expectancy and the disproportionate disease
burden exist perhaps because of inadequate education, disproportionate poverty, discrimination
in the delivery of health services and cultural differences. These are broad quality of life
issues rooted in economic adversity and poor social conditions. American Indians and Alaskan
Natives born today have a life expectancy that is 5.5 years less than the U.S. all races population.
The specific reasons for health disparities are complex and represent much more than who American
Indian and Alaskan Natives are. They also represent where people live and the services available and
accessible to them. Factors such as having a regular source of care, language and communication
barriers, lack of diversity in the health care workforce, high rates of poverty, lack of insurance
coverage, discrimination and large distances from health care services have all added to
the disparities. Go ahead and go to the next slide, please.
It is important to note that although the trauma history that I've shared is a part of the story,
it is just that, a part of the story. Our history is also a history of vast cultural knowledge,
wisdom, ceremony and practices, resilience and survival. Additionally, some tribal nations are
defining their own social determinants of health, and they are also defining their own
social determinants of health, including factors such as cultural identity, family,
participation in cultural activities, access to Native lands and natural resources.
With this in mind, it is important to consider specific cultural strategies
to address public health prevention for American Indian and Alaskan Native populations
as a result of the previously mentioned unique social determinants of health and health
disparities. I want to highlight tribal practices for wellness in Indian country,
which will be discussed in more detail later in the presentation as a key example that supports
tribal practices as a path to prevention and wellness promotion in American Indian and Alaskan
Native communities. A TIPWIC is a four-year cooperative agreement of American Indian and
Alaskan Native tribes and Alaska Native villages or tribally designated organizations that work
with tribes. There's 15 urban Indian organizations receiving a total of approximately 5 million per
year. So the mission of TIPWIC is to encourage and support tribal practices that build resiliency
and connections to community, family and culture. Seven strategies are employed toward this mission.
Connect cultural teachings to health and wellness, support seasonal cultural practices that support
health and wellness, implement social and cultural activities that promote community wellness,
establish and maintain collaborations that strengthen well-being, support intergenerational
learning for well-being and resilience, promote traditional healthy foods and promote traditional
and contemporary physical activities. It's important to note in addressing public health
for American Indian and Alaskan Native population, it's important to build flexibility into the
cooperative agreement or program to allow American Indian and Alaskan Native populations
to bring cultural and traditional adaptations that work individually for their community.
Flexibility per tribal nation is important as not one tribal nation is the same and their
experiences are all different and their traditions and cultural are all unique to them. Next slide,
please. So shifting to looking at public health infrastructure and important partners in Indian
country. So public health infrastructure provides communities, states and the nation with the
capacity to prevent disease, promote health and prepare for and respond to acute threats
and challenges to health. Infrastructure is the foundation for planning, delivering, evaluating
and improving public health and enables the public health system to function including a workforce
training and public health core competencies, information and data systems for rapidly
assessing and communicating information and the ability to respond to public health needs
in culturally responsive and relevant ways. Some tribes look at public health more like community
health where it's an extension to health care services. So in this section we will go into more
detail of tribal public health infrastructure and how CDC works with tribal nations and their
public health infrastructure. This section will also discuss tribal partners in more detail.
Next slide, please. So I wanted to just share briefly the differences between Title I and
Title V, also known as 638. So when we look at Title I, Tribally Contracted Facilities,
they are run by federally recognized tribes or organizations with the IHS to plan, conduct and
administer one or more individual programs, functions, services or activities or portions
thereof that IHS would otherwise provide for Indians because of their status as American
Indian and Alaska Natives. For Title V, Tribally Compacted Facilities, they're run by federally
recognized tribes or tribal organizations with the IHS to assume full funding and control over
programs, services, functions or activities or portions thereof that IHS would otherwise provide.
So my tribe, the Choctaw Nation of Oklahoma is a 638. So they have elected to run the full array
of services for the Choctaw Nation. Go ahead and go to the next slide, please.
So both Title V and Title I for tribal administration or programs formerly administered
by IHS, the major difference is a matter of oversight. So under Title V, a tribe may redesign
or consolidate programs, services, functions or activities, also known as PSFAs because we in the
government love our acronyms and reallocate or redirect funding without IHS approval in accordance
with the Indian Self-Determination Education Act. In contrast, IHS must approve any substantial
changes to a Title I contract. The programs aren't not exclusive because tribes can choose
which PSFAs or portions to assume. A tribe may combine Title V, Title I and direct services to
best meet the needs of its communities and Tribal 638 programs are eligible for federally
qualified health center grants at FQHC. Go ahead and go to the next slide, please.
So urban Indians not only share the same health problems as the general American Indian and Alaska
Native population, but their problems may be exacerbated in terms of mental and physical
hardships because of the lack of family and traditional cultural environments.
It is important to understand the different partners that contribute to urban Indian health
as approximately 70% of American Indians and Alaska Natives live in urban areas.
Go ahead and go to the next slide, please.
Urban Indian Health Centers. So these are designated federally qualified health centers
that provide comprehensive primary care and related services to American Indians and Alaska
Natives. The facilities are owned or leased by urban Indian organizations and receive grant and
contract funding through Title V of the Indian Health Care Improvement Act. This is a picture
of the Missoula Urban Indian Health Center in Missoula, Montana. Go ahead and go to the next
slide, please. The IHS provides contracts and grants to 41 urban centered nonprofit
urban Indian organizations providing healthcare services at 59 locations throughout the United
States. The 41 programs engage in a variety of culturally appropriate activities to increase
access to health services for urban Indians. The National Council of Urban Indian Health,
or NACUI, is a national nonprofit devoted to the support and development of quality, accessible,
and culturally competent health services for American Indians and Alaska Natives living
in urban settings. Next slide, please. So before we move on to Indian health boards and tribal
epicenters, we have a question in the box. Does OTASTA have resources on which tribes are Title
I versus Title V? Similarly, are these resources on which tribes use BIA police officers compared
to tribal police departments? So this is a complicated question when you are looking at
BIA and police officers and how tribal police departments function. So I would need a little
bit more time to unpack that one, but we do have some resources that we could point you to as far
as Title I versus Title V. And I will share an email at the end of the presentation if you want
to reach out to us. I would be so happy to talk with you about that offline. So let's go to the
Indian health boards and tribal epicenters. So these partners work with tribal nations and urban
Indian health organizations to support and fill in gaps in health care programs and essential
public health services. Go ahead and go to the next slide, please.
Area Indian health boards are nonprofit tribal advisory organizations run and organized by
participating tribes. Most focused on four areas as they pertain to the health of American Indian
Alaska Native people. Health promotion and disease prevention, legislative and policy analysis,
training and technical assistance, and surveillance and research.
You see on the slide that there's 12 regional tribally designated organizations run and
organized by participating tribal nations. So we have the Alaska Native health board for the
Alaska area. And these also are connected to the 12 areas for Indian health service.
As you may or may not be aware, HHS has 10 regions, but Indian health service has 12
areas. So we have the Alaska Native health board, the Albuquerque area Indian health board,
the Great Lakes area tribal health board, Rocky Mountain tribal leaders council,
California rural Indian health board, Great Plains tribal chairman's health board,
Northwest Portland area health board, inner tribal council of Arizona, the Southern Plains
tribal health board, the Navajo Nation Department of Health, and the United South and Eastern tribes.
And this picture depicts the Indian health board of Minneapolis. Go ahead and go to the next slide,
please. Additionally, the national Indian health board or NIHB is a nonprofit organization that
represents tribal governments, both those that operate their own health care delivery systems
through contracting and compacting and those receiving health care directly from IHS. The
area health board serve as member organizations of the national Indian health board and the
communication link between the NIHB and tribes. Member organizations advise in the development
of positions on health policy, planning, and program design. They gather information and
review public opinion and proposals. In areas without an area health board,
the NIHB representative communicates policy information and concerns to the tribes in that
area. Go ahead and go to the next slide, please. Additionally, tribal epidemiology center or TECS
are Indian health service division funded organizations who serve American Indian
Alaska Native tribal and urban communities by managing public health information systems,
investigating diseases of concern, managing disease prevention and control programs,
and responding to public health emergencies and coordinating these activities with other
public health authorities. Each TEC is unique in terms of the types and range of activities
conducted and services offered. There are 12 TECs in total with different missions and activities
per their area. Go ahead and go to the next slide, please.
So in this next subsection, we'll provide details on federal agencies and how they partner with
tribal nations, including a few highlights of projects supporting public health infrastructure
in Indian country. Most federal work with American Indian Alaska Native tribal nations and urban
American AIA and individuals flows from two federal departments, Department of the Interior
and Department of Health and Human Services. Go ahead and go to the next slide, please.
Key federal partners working with tribal nations include the Department of Interior. The BIA is
the oldest agency of the U.S. Department of Interior. The BIA carries out its core mission
to serve the federally recognized tribes through four offices, the Office of Indian Services.
That office operates BIA's general assistance, disaster relief, Indian child welfare, tribal
government, Indian self-determination, and reservation roads programs. When I first started
my career, I'm a licensed clinical social worker by training. I started out at a small clinic in
Wewoka, Oklahoma, and I worked closely with this office related to general assistance and Indian
child welfare. The Office of Justice Services directly operates or funds law enforcement,
tribal courts, detention facilities, or on federal Indian lands. The Office of Trust Services works
with tribes and individual American Indian and Alaska Natives in the management of their trust
land assets and resources. And finally, the Office of Field Operations oversees 12 regional offices
and 83 agencies which carry out the mission at the Bureau at the tribal level. We also have the
Bureau of Indian Education. It provides education services from early childhood through life in
accordance with the tribe's needs for cultural and economic well-being. Within the Department of
Health and Human Services, the public health service agencies include Indian Health Service,
and IHS is responsible for providing federal health care services to American Indians and
Alaska Natives. IHS, as I shared before, has 12 area offices and 170 IHS and tribally managed
service units. The Food and Drug Administration ensures that food is safe and pure and wholesome.
The Health Resources and Services Administration provides health care to people who are geographically
isolated economically, medically vulnerable. The National Institutes of Health supports
biomedical and behavioral research. And the Substance Use Mental Health Services Administration
improves access and reduces barriers to high quality effective programs and services
for individuals who may suffer or are at risk of addictive and mental health disorders. And of
course, the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention. Go to the next slide, please.
So I wanted to shift gears just a little bit and share with you
the Tribal Behavioral Health Agenda. So an example, this is an example really of how
agencies are collaborating with tribes. So the Substance Abuse and Mental Health Services
Administration or SAMHSA and Indian Health Service worked with the National Indian Health Board
to gather input from tribal leaders and other relevant partners to develop the National Tribal
Behavioral Health Agenda. So the TBHA, it's not a strategic plan. It's rather a guiding blueprint
that will assist in strengthening policies and programs, aligning disparate resources and
facilitating collaboration. It identifies existing strategic plans and efforts that can serve
as initial pathways for action. And as a single unifying tool, which engaged partners, it can
gather utilizing common language and priorities. And I know several tribal citizens that worked
on this Tribal Behavioral Health Agenda and it was really a labor of love for them.
It addresses five foundational elements, historical and intergenerational trauma,
national awareness and visibility, social ecological approaches, prevention and recovery
supports, and behavioral health services and systems improvement. It really works to provide
a clear national statement about the extent of behavioral health related problems and their
impact on the well-being of tribal communities. It identifies the foundational elements that I
shared. It also provides actions that tribal, federal, state, and local governments in the
private sector should consider based on evidence and practice-based strategies.
It elevates priorities for actions that could or are likely to contribute to meaningful progress
and tackling persistent behavioral health problems for Native youth families and communities.
And it guides the development of strategies that over time more cohesively address factors that
contribute to improved emotional health. And there's a link here to the Tribal Behavioral
Health Agenda if you have an interest in reading it more fully. Next slide, please.
So, I have a question that says, might you be aware or know the status of the Office of Minority
Health's initiative to create a Center for Indigenous Innovation and Health Equity Center?
Yes, I am aware of this. I attended a listening session last week about the creation of the Center
on the Office of Minority Health website. There should be slides from that listening
session that can give you more information if you have interest. I know they are also
recruiting elected tribal leaders to serve on their newly formed Tribal Advisory Committee.
So, they are asking for help to publicize that as well. And reference the recording of this webinar,
I am not sure. I know it's being recorded and we can address that at the end of the session.
So, as we shift gears, the CDC has several projects related to tribal public health
infrastructure. I wanted to talk about these projects now that I've explained and discussed
historical factors and components of health in tribal communities. I'm going to highlight
a few of these projects supporting public health infrastructure. Please understand that
in this limited time, this is not an exhaustive list of projects as supporting tribal public
health infrastructure. Just trying to give a few highlights. Go ahead and go to the next slide,
please. Direct funding of American Indian and Alaska Native tribes and organizations.
Direct funding allows tribal nations to compete with agencies of similar infrastructure. States
get direct funding for many public health issues and tribal nations must rely on states to pass
funding down through them. Moreover, funding that is specific for tribal nations but also
allow more flexibility to account for cultural and traditional best practices. CDC ATSDR currently
has multiple direct funding opportunities to tribal nations and tribally designated
organizations that help support public health efforts and support capacity building in Indian
country. Listed on this slide are some examples of funding to tribes and tribal organizations.
I'll talk a bit more about each of these funding mechanisms throughout this section. Go ahead and
go to the next slide, please. I mentioned the tribal epicenters a little bit earlier in the
presentation. The tribal epidemiology center public health infrastructure or tech fee is a CDC
cooperative agreement that complements Indian health service funding to increase the tech's
public health capacity and infrastructure. The purpose of tech fee is to reduce programmatic
silos within the techs and expand their ability to perform the seven core functions by building
data infrastructure, increasing staff capacity and establishing partnerships. CDC supports the
12 techs and one network coordinating center. The network coordinating center coordinates the
evaluation of this initiative and provides project organization, logistics and communications across
the techs. Tech fee is a five-year cooperative agreement and the techs receive a total of
approximately 8.5 million per year. Although each of the techs projects are unique, they are all
engaging in the following three key strategies to contribute to overall health for American,
Indian and Alaska Native people nationwide. Strengthening public health capacity and
infrastructure, implementing activities to improve effectiveness of health promotion
and disease prevention, engaging in sustainable activities after the funding cycle ends.
The program intends to reduce chronic diseases and risk factors, reduce disparities in health
outcomes and improve overall health by building public health capacity and infrastructure in
Indian country for disease surveillance, epidemiology, prevention and control of disease,
injury or disability. And you see on this slide where all of the techs are located and
they are within the 12 Indian health service areas. Go ahead and go to the next slide, please.
Tribal practices for wellness in Indian country is a four-year cooperative agreement.
American, Indian, Alaska tribes and Alaska Native villages are tribally designated organizations
that work with tribes and 15 urban Indian organizations receive a total of approximately
$5 million per year. TIPWIC encourages and supports tribal practices that build resiliency
and connections to community, family and culture. Over time, these can reduce risk factors for
chronic disease and promote wellness among American, Indian and Alaska Natives.
The CDC funds 36 tribes and urban Indian health centers through TIPWIC. The TIPWIC strategies
fall into the following three general areas. Health promotion, increased traditional physical
activity, traditional foods and overall healthy living practices. Cultural practices, increased
knowledge and sharing of tribal history and cultural practices. Social and emotional wellbeing,
an increased sense of belonging to tribe, sense of connection to culture and intergenerational
interactions are having a positive impact on wellbeing. And this slide represents the states
where the recipients are located. And as you see, we have recipients at several places on
the map. Go ahead and go to the next slide, please. I now like to talk about good health
and wellness in Indian country. Good health and wellness in Indian country continues to
support healthy behaviors for American, Indian, Alaska Natives and emphasizes strategies to reduce
risk factors in Native communities to attain long-term goals by supporting a coordinated
and holistic approach to healthy living and chronic disease prevention. Work also is going
toward reinforcing the work already underway in Indian country to make healthy choices easier for
American Indians and Alaska Natives. Continuing to support culturally appropriate effective public
health approaches and working with more tribes and extending the program's reach and impact through
tribal organizations, including urban Indian organizations. Long-term goals include reducing
type 2 diabetes, reducing commercial tobacco use, reducing high blood pressure and high blood
cholesterol, increasing the intake of healthy foods and physical activity, and also increasing
breastfeeding. Go ahead and go to the next slide, please. Now I'd like to share a little bit about
the Tribal Public Health Capacity Building and Quality Improvement Umbrella Cooperative Grant,
also known as OT18-1803. This program's purpose is to provide resources for American Indian and
Alaska Native tribal nations and regional American Indian Alaska Native tribally designated
organizations to optimize the quality and performance of the tribal public health system,
including infrastructure, workforce data, and information systems, programs and services,
resources and communication, and also partnerships. Work in these areas will increase the capacity of
Indian country to identify, respond to, and mitigate public health threats and decrease
burden of disease among American Indian and Alaska Natives. This cooperative agreement
is in its fourth year of funding. OT18-1803 strategic areas and proposed activities work
toward addressing eight of the ten essential public health services. Tribal public health system
infrastructure encompassing developing policies, workforce assuring a competent workforce,
tribal public health partnership encompassing mobilizing community partnerships,
tribal public health programs and services linking to care and investigations, tribal public health
resources and communication encompasses informing, educating, and empowering, and tribal data and
information systems evaluating and monitoring health. Go ahead and go to the next slide please.
And on this slide you see our OT18-1803 recipients. This cooperative agreement awards 25 federally
recognized American Indian and Alaska Native tribal nations and regionally tribal designated
organizations. So 14 tribal nations and 11 regional tribal organizations. Go ahead and go to the next
slide please. And here is a map showing the recipients. Wisconsin, Oklahoma, and Washington
states have the most representation. Go ahead and go to the next slide please.
So this slide just shares the funding strategies under OT18-1803. Funding strategy one and funding
strategy two. This cooperative agreement is an umbrella cooperative agreement allowing CDC CIOs
to provide additional project plans to support public health infrastructure through the second
funding strategy. The funding strategy is the base funding providing 22,000 to each recipient
for public health infrastructure under the six strategies mentioned previously.
Recipients receiving the base funding are then eligible for funding strategy two projects
allowing for less competition for direct funding. Funding strategy two was created to maximize CDC
programs priorities and health system needs in Indian country. The funding provides recipients
opportunities for substantial topic specific funding. There are currently six CIOs that have
projects funded under strategy two. Go ahead and go to the next slide please.
So I'd like to share with you now some project examples of OT18-03. The Forest County Potawatomi
community have an agreement for expanding tribal members access to health and wellness resources,
increasing engagement in community events and supporting the involvement of tribal members
and prioritizing and addressing the community's public health needs.
FCPC was able to improve their data and knowledge of their community health by conducting needs
assessments while also improving the recipient's outreach to their community. FCPC has enrolled
tribal members and their family affiliates in the managed well health system and has been better
able to understand the health and concerns of the community through biometric screenings and health
assessments as part of their enrollment. I'm going to pause here and plug in my headphones,
stand by. My headphones said they have had too much talking so thank you for that. So the Rocky
Mountain Tribal Leaders Council is supporting a public health workforce expansion in Indian
Country project modeled after CDC's public health associate program. They partnered with
seven tribal colleges where students are selected and complete quick impact projects centered around
behavioral health. This initiative to improve the public health workforce for American Indian
and Alaska Natives also successfully developed another position within the recipient's organization
to initiate partnership development amongst colleges. This position has been able to be
sustainable by the recipient for a long-term partnership involvement. And lastly, the public
health accreditation standards. This has multiple recipients. Multiple 1803 recipients are addressing
public health accreditation standards. Standards include development and implementation of
communication plans, community health assessments, strategic planning, community health improvement
plans, and continuity of operation plans as well as data improvement among others. So Chickasaw
Nation has been able to complete the big three. The community health assessment and also the
community health improvement plan and strategic plan and is preparing to officially apply for
PHAB accreditation. Cherokee Nation is working towards re-accreditation and the Gila River
Eastern Band of Cherokee Indians, Choctaw Nation, Ho-Chunk Nation, Lummi Nation,
Wabanaki Health and Wellness, and White Earthland of Chippewa Indians are all progressing in PHAB
standards. Go ahead and go to the next slide please. There we go. So through the 1803
cooperative agreement, CDC provides almost 60 million dollars through supplements to an
existing CDC cooperative agreement, tribal public health capacity building and quality improvement.
This includes about 39 million dollars to 12 regional tribal organizations to serve 10
HHS regions and four tribal nations serving populations of 40,000 or more to prevent,
prepare for, and respond to COVID-19 and 12 million dollars to 11 regional American Indian
and Alaska Native tribally designated organizations to build public health capacity during the COVID-19
response and recovery. The OT 1803 cooperative agreement acted as an already existing funding
mechanism to rapidly provide COVID-19 supplemental funding to regional organizations in response to
the pandemic. The CDC ATSDR tribal advisor committee that will be discussed in more detail
later has requested continued funding and expansion of recipients for this cooperative agreement.
A new umbrella NOFO is expected in 2023. Go ahead and go to the next slide please.
The Supporting Tribal Public Health Capacity in Coronavirus Preparedness and Response Grant or OT
20 2004. In addition to the already existing funding mechanism OT 1803, CDC developed a new grant
to provide COVID-19 funding direct to tribal nations and organizations. This is a non-competitive
grant that provides funding to 346 tribal recipients. This includes 290 tribal nations,
25 tribal consortia, and 31 tribal organizations which reach more than 490 tribes
and more than 39 million individuals according to grantee self-report. Go ahead and go to the next
slide please. Additionally, the Strengthening Public Health Systems and Services through
National Partnerships to Improve and Protect the Nation's Health Cooperative Agreement or OT
18 1802. The purpose of this initiative is to strengthen the nation's public health
infrastructure, ensure a confident current and connected public health system, and improve the
delivery of 10 essential public health services through capacity building assistance. The program
strategies include strengthening the capacities of public health systems infrastructure, leadership,
and workforce, data and information systems, communication and information technology,
partnerships, law and policies, and programs and services. Partners will deliver capacity
building assistance through technical assistance, training, information, sharing, technology
transfer, materials development, or funding that enables organizations to serve customers better
and operate in a comprehensive, responsive, and effective manner. Organizations working on
tribal-related projects who received awards through this cooperative agreement include,
but are not limited to, the National Council of Urban Indian Health NACUI, the National Indian
Health Board, NIHB, and the National Network of Public Health Institutes. Next slide please.
I want to shift just a minute and talk about working with tribal nations training.
This training was created by NIHB with funding and support from the Center for Disease Control
and Prevention, CDC. The Working with Tribes training course is part of NIHB's aim to increase
familiarity with tribes throughout all levels of government, elevate tribal health care and
public health needs, and improve non-tribal government employees' familiarity and comfort
with working with tribes. The training module was created using input from area Indian health boards
and other tribal partners, CDC staff, and other federal staff and non-tribal stakeholders.
The training underwent two rounds of pilot testing and review prior to the public release.
It may also be useful for other professionals such as those who are working with tribal leaders or
conducting consultation activities. Additionally, the first module of the course provides general
information on the impacts of colonization and historical trauma on tribal nations.
That may be more widely useful for those who want to learn more about the experience of
this nation's indigenous peoples. You can access this training if you have interest on the NIHB's
website. Go ahead and go to the next slide please.
Racial misclassification of American Indian and Alaska Native people in dangerous lives.
It marginalizes American Indian and Alaska Native people and leaves the organizations that serve
them without sufficient data to make decisions or fund the services they provide. This report
examines the problem of racial misclassification on death certificates with a particular focus on
the role of funeral directors in urban communities. For over a year, the National Council of Urban
Indian Health investigated possible factors that might create racial misclassification and looked
for solutions to prevent these factors. This document is intended as a broad and introductory
guide for a variety of stakeholders that can help prevent this problem, including funeral directors,
businesses, and industry associations, statisticians, and public health experts,
and policy stakeholders. The report consists of five parts, a review of the vital record
systems, racial misclassification of deaths, and relevant literature on this topic, a description
of the survey, listening sessions, and interviews conducted by NACUI to learn about funeral director
policies, practices, and experiences, results from these activities, and then a discussion
summarizing what NACUI has learned, and a list of recommendations geared at the prevention of racial
misclassifications on death certificates before it occurs. Go ahead and go to the next slide, please.
The Public Health and Indian Country Capacity Scan, or FICS, the National Indian Health Board
in partnership with the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention released the 2019 Public
Health and Indian Country Capacity Scan that provides a comprehensive picture of tribal public
health infrastructure and activities, specifically immunization, screening, and prevention education
activities that are widely occurring in Indian Country. This report describes the current state
of public health services from a national perspective throughout tribal communities.
The 2019 FICS report serves as a valuable tool for Indian Country to identify needs and strengths
in tribal public health, to measure progress over time, to allocate staff and resources where they
are most needed, and provide data for decision making relative to infrastructure programs and
resources for the system overall. And you find a link on this side to this FICS report if you have
interest. Okay, go ahead and go to the next slide, please. Let me look at some of these questions.
So I had a question that talks about how are policies being socialized with Native American
communities? Seems there is no knowledge of primary health care. Also, how can I help as an ally?
So my experience is that there has been really a swell of interest in American Indian and Alaska
Native communities and education about primary health care. But a lot of the focus is on primary
health care rather than public health as a whole. And the question said that there was a treaty camp
in Minnesota. I would be very interested to hear more about that. There's a question related to
the five million fixed amount or increase with inflation budget. I'm not really sure which
cooperative agreement or grant that's referring to. Could you describe some of the reasons for
spotty uptake? So it is difficult for many tribal nations to be able to have the infrastructure,
to be able to apply for cooperative agreements and grants, and then be able to run them. Also,
some of the funding can be a small amount with these particular grants. But it gets
a tribal nation kind of into play in looking at public health and building that infrastructure.
So I think we have to look at ways to support that and then supplemental funding that can
add on to the work that's being done to develop the public health infrastructure for that tribal
nation. The next question is, we know there has been understandable concerns about biomonitoring
within tribes and Native communities in the past. Was this project more successful? If so,
do you think that was a result of being tribally led? Yes. I think any cooperative agreement or
grant that starts where a tribe is and really focuses on that tribe's needs and supports that
and has flexibility to be tailored to specific tribal needs is always going to be more successful.
As far as to confirm public health services, are tribal public health requirements a success?
Yes, there are requirements by states. I'm sorry, and I apologize. You can't see what I'm reading.
It says to confirm public health services are in agreement with CDC. Are tribal public health
required to submit specific test results as with STIs and with TB? There are some state requirements
that states work with tribes in order to be able to access that information.
Let's see, and where can we find more about the Racial Misclassification Project?
If you email me, I'm at rqj0 at cdc.gov. I will get you those links. So let's see. In our remaining
time, I'd like to go a little bit into CDC's Tribal Advisory Committee and Tribal Consultation.
Go ahead and go to the next slide. Regarding government-to-government relations,
the CDC ATSDR Tribal Advisory Committee is a key component upholding this relationship.
The Tribal Advisory Committee advises CDC ATSDR on policy issues and broad strategies that may
significantly affect American Indian and Alaska Native communities. The TAC assists CDC ATSDR
in fulfilling its mission to remote health and quality of life by preventing and controlling
disease injury and disability through established and ongoing relationships and consultation
sessions. Maintaining the CDC ATSDR TAC is one of OTAS' roles. The TAC is a committee made up of
elected tribal leaders or their authorized representative. The TAC provides advice and
recommendations to CDC ATSDR in accordance with Executive Order 13175. They meet formally twice
a year through formal public health meetings to discuss American Indian and Alaska Native priorities
and provide feedback on important issues affecting Indian Country. TAC roles include identifying
evolving issues and barriers, proposing clarifications, recommendations, and solutions,
serving as a forum for tribal nations, and identifying priorities and providing advice.
Go ahead and go to the next slide, please. CDC ATSDR's Tribal Advisory Committee is composed
of elected tribal leaders or their designated authorized representative. So its composition
includes one delegate from each IHS region, and as we showed before, there's 12 of those,
and four delegates from tribes at large. The Office of Tribal Affairs and Strategic
Alliances, my office, administers the TAC, including implementing and coordinating the
biannual TAC meetings. Historically, those TAC meetings have been one meeting in Atlanta and
one meeting somewhere in Indian Country. The designated federal official is Dr. Jose Montero,
who I shared before as the Director for Seastelts. TAC functions and serves as scientific and
programmatic resource. He, CDC ATSDR managers and staff, as determined by the designated federal
official, serve as resources for the TAC as well. Go ahead and go to the next slide, please.
CDC ATSDR's Tribal Consultation Policy requires that CDC and ATSDR programs consult with tribal
governments when developing programs, policies, and activities that will affect American Indian
and Alaska Native populations. The goals of this consultation are to assist in eliminating
the health disparities faced by American Indian and Alaska Native tribes, ensuring health equity
for all American Indian and Alaska Native people and communities is attained, maximizing access to
critical health and human services and public health services to enhance the social, physical,
and economic status of American Indian and Alaska Native tribes. Tribal consultation current status.
So we have been hard at work to honor the presidential memorandum that was issued on January
26, 2021, directing us to take a look at our tribal consultation policy and have consultation
on this policy to see how we might improve it to better meet the needs of the tribal nations that
we serve. So we recently held this tribal consultation on August 5th. We are on track
to provide a formal response and a summary report to the testimonies provided by November 11th.
Go ahead and go to the next slide, please.
So as stated earlier, the CDC ATSDR TAC is made up of tribal leaders from each of the different
IHS areas. While the TAC members can be used as subject matter experts to provide guidance
on perspectives from each of their respective areas, they are really only able to represent
their specific tribal nation. One tribe cannot speak for another and therefore the TAC really
can't act as a substitute for consultation. One tribal leader commented in a recent consultation
session that the CDC ATSDR should begin engaging the TAC early in the policy and regulatory making
process so any proposed policies can be tribally informed from the start. Consultation is necessary
once an action such as policy, funding development, program services has been identified that
significantly impacts American Indian and Alaska Native populations or even one tribal nation.
It can occur across all federally recognized tribal nations or just one tribe. Who is in
attendance is dependent on who the policy or issue impacts. It's also important to understand
the difference between consultation and listening sessions. Consultation should occur when a formal
decision needs to be made on an activity that has a large impact on tribal nations while a listening
session is to obtain informal guidance during very early stages of a project. Listening sections can
also be used to get guidance on an activity or program that has lower level implications for
tribal nations. Go ahead and go to the next slide please. So moving forward. Next slide.
To summarize the different items we have discussed throughout this presentation,
some important considerations should include direct and continuous funding sources for
tribal nations to plan for resources ahead of time and have sustainable resources to build
infrastructure and capacity. Improve data access and quality of data to prioritize resources.
Flexible programs and funding opportunities to account for cultural and traditional practices
that might be more effective in addressing public health prevention for American Indian
and Alaska Native communities and respect for cultural practices and community ways of knowing.
When working with tribal nations and tribal partners, it is important to include tribal
leaders at the beginning of planning together input on what might be most needed with regards
to that area of public health prevention. Continuously communicating throughout the
development of a project will ensure improved buy-in as well as more effective strategies to
address that population's needs. Lastly, it is important not to make assumptions.
Always listen and when in doubt, ask questions. I want to end this point with a story that I
experienced really early in my career related to making assumptions. I was working with a very
respected tribal researcher and she shared a story with me about a tribal nation that had reached out
for assistance with trying to turn around the tide on pediatric obesity within their tribe.
The research team went to this tribal nation with some preconceptions about why this was happening,
about what would be needed, and about how to move forward. They started out in the community
sharing these preconceived conceptions and they felt like they weren't getting very far.
And then one day they were at a community center and there was some discussion and some elders
shared that this particular tribe had experienced earlier in their tribal history a very significant
famine and many people died, especially babies and smaller children. And the babies and smaller
children that had survived had been the heavier kids and this had translated into a value for
heavier children and I perceived that it was their cultural way for children to
be that healthy equals heavier or a heavier weight.
As this was discussed and realized, they realized that this value had not been part of their
original instructions that had been adaptive to what had happened to them. If these researchers
had not talked to the elders of the community, they would have never realized this and they would
have never been able to incorporate this knowledge into their interventions. And surely this issue
was multifactorial, that this was a huge part in the piece of the puzzle that they needed to be
able to work with this tribe to be able to have effective interventions. So I encourage you as
you work with tribal partners to always have an open listening ear, to have that respect
and have that desire to not make assumptions and answer those questions.
So go ahead and go to the next slide please.
These are some ways that you can connect with OTASA and Sea Stilts. The
at the tribal page, the cdc.gov backslash tribal has a lot of the documents that I have referenced
here. You can find our TAC charter, you can find our current CDC tribal consultation policy,
you can learn more about our tribal resources. Additionally, if you want to reach out to me
directly, I'll put my email in the chat box and with that I just go to the last slide please.
I just want to thank you very sincerely. I've been honored to be able to spend this time with
you today and I am so thankful for the work that all of you are doing and OTASA stands ready to
support as you work with tribal nations in any way.
Thank you so much Captain here. I really, really appreciate it. There are a couple of questions in
the Q&A box that have added up but I'd be interested to see, there's one person
that put in a link to the racial misclassification report and there's, I don't know if that's the
but I wanted to get your okay before it approves.
And I have a couple questions if you want to answer the Q&A box. Go ahead.
So as there's a question, given the unique conditions of Native Hawaiian communities,
is there a mechanism TAC for supporting Native Hawaiian communities in Hawaii?
Noticeably, Hawaii State is linked out in a TAC map. So Native Hawaiians have a different
relationship with the United States government than the 574 federally recognized tribes.
So the TAC supports that government to government relationship that we have with the 574
federally recognized tribes. I do know that CDC does do some work with Native Hawaiian communities
and works to support those communities as well but they do not have formal TAC representation
because of that unique government to government relationships for federally recognized tribes.
I have, I'm wondering whether there are general resources available for CDC employees to support
culturally appropriate engagement with tribal partners? Yes. So if you have interest in
learning more, I would encourage you to go to the NIHB website and take the training that I
discussed earlier. I can also, I'm so bad at multitasking. I used to be a police dispatcher
way, way back in my career and I could do it all but I can't do it now. So maybe we can get
somebody to drop that in the link, the NIHB website. I would also encourage you to visit
the CDC tribal page. There's a lot of resources there. Additionally, you can always reach out to
OTASA if you have any particular needs and we would be happy to help locate that. Let's see,
next I have given the data modernization initiatives at CDC. Is there a plan to do
a tribal consultation for that alignment of surveillance data across centers at CDC?
For example, there are often different mechanisms for tribes to share data. So we do have a data
modernization work group that is addressing tribal data as well. I think as these plans
kind of come together, we have suggested for some listening sessions and tribal consultation
when these plans kind of align. So yes, stand by for that because I believe that those are going
to be next steps coming with that. Let's see. The other question was about the data modernization
initiative that I shared, how are tribal issues being addressed. If you had an opportunity in
August to listen in to our tribal advisory committee, we had one section that was dedicated
to data modernization issues so that we could hear from the tech about what their experiences
were. A lot came to light about data related to COVID-19 and how tribes were able to access
information and respond. And so the stars are aligning in ways I believe that we are going
to have some movement forward related to DMI. Also, just as an aside, everyone from CDC is
welcome to be in a listening mode on our TAC meetings. Our next TAC is going to be February
2nd and 3rd. If you visit the tribal website that I referenced earlier, you can see registration
so that you can. And those meetings are very, very informative about a variety of issues.
In August, we talked about public health infrastructure. We talked about social
determinants of health. We talked about DMI and opioids. I know I'm missing something, but
the TAC meetings are now being focused to be less CDC presentation and more hearing from the tribal
leaders. And so I think that has made them a little bit richer as well. Let's see.
Are there programs that provide funding to hire tribal members to work on public health issues
within their own communities? So we have the key health, the public health associates program.
We have really strived to identify more tribal host sites and to encourage recruitment of
American Indian Alaskan Native PHAPs. Additionally, the AmeriCorps public health program has just
launched, which tribes are eligible for as well. I would encourage you, if you're working with
tribal nations, to make them aware of these resources because with these AmeriCorps funds,
they could potentially hire tribal members or American Indian Alaskan Natives to work on these
public health issues in their communities. Let's see. So I believe that that is the end of the
questions. Do you see any that I'm missing? Oh, okay. I want to give a shout out. I see
not a question, but I just wanted to say that I used to work with Dr. Katie Scheltz, and she
wanted me to let you know that she says hello. So Katie Scheltz was one of the inaugural members
on our Yachtley Walk in 2012 with Indigenous Wellness Research, and she's a Choctaw by way
of Alaska and one of my very good friends. So please tell Dr. Scheltz I said hello. So good
to hear from her. I think that's the end of the questions. Are there any other questions? I think
we have five minutes. Am I reading that right? You're correct. Well, thank you so much for that.
I mean, such a broad-sweeping overview of American Indian Alaskan Native issues in the country
and as well as the past, present, and future. I very much appreciate your work, and I thought
it was especially touching the personal stories you had and how that really made it relatable to
the activities that occur today and the different things that are going on. I was wondering if you
could talk briefly, and just probably one final question, a little bit about jurisdictions in
Indian country and how those interact, and particularly from the public health realm as
far as county health departments, IHS, BIA, all those folks. And if you can talk briefly about
that, that's a complex topic, but I think it's a topic our learners don't understand as much.
Right, and it's a very complicated topic, and it varies from state to state, tribe to tribe,
county to county. Some tribal nations have established pretty good working relationships
with their county health departments or their state health departments. Others definitely do
not. We hear from tribes that monies that flow through state health departments that are intended
to serve American Indian Alaskan Natives sometimes do not end up there or in the way that the tribal
nations would request them to. We've also heard, especially with the COVID-19 vaccines,
so tribes had the choice to get their vaccines through Indian Health Service or to go through
the states for vaccine. Many tribes felt that they should be able to work directly government
to government with that, or that they should have the choice maybe to do both, and so that added to
some complexity. Also, additionally, it's difficult because, as I shared, the majority
of American Indian Alaskan Natives live in urban centers, and so they might be served by a county
health department. They might be served by an urban Indian organization. So how does that all
work together? Additionally, as we look at data as well, although many of the sites ask if you're
American Indian or Alaskan Native, I don't believe any sites are asking, are you Choctaw?
Are you Cherokee? So then how do tribal nations identify within their data their tribal members
and what services they're getting and how? I had an experience in my own public health department,
so I get some of my services through Choctaw Nation. I get some of my services through
the county health department, and when I went for my flu shot, they didn't ask if I was American
Indian or Alaskan Native. They automatically just looked at me and made an assumption
and checked why. So I just say, whoa, whoa, wait a minute, you know, check this because I want to be
represented, right? And so that goes to that misclassification as well. Additionally, so as
I think public health infrastructure for tribes is, for most tribes, is just very much at the
beginning, right? Because, you know, county, states have been inventing for a long time for
public health infrastructure, but there hasn't really been a dedicated funding source for these
activities for Indian country. And so as they become more robust, like Cherokee Nation, and
they say state of Oklahoma, we're able to take on these activities for our citizens, then what does
that mean for funds that come to the state of Oklahoma, and how does that also, I think that
kind of can be very complicated as well. Plus, if you have a tribe that, say, has 50,000 tribal
members, then it might be kind of in your best interest to stand that up and have that and be
able, but if you have a rancheria that, say, has less than 100, you know, are you going to be able
to take on all those essential services? So I think the picture can be very different for
many, many reasons, and so that's, I think, why, you know, there's still so much work to be left,
left to be done, you know, for, as we stand up, public health infrastructure.
Certainly. Well, thank you, Captain Heard. We're at the top of the hour. We very much appreciate
your time and your efforts in this area. If you're listening, we're going to, for our audience,
we're going to be back on December 1st. We'll be tentatively talking about big data and large
data analysis. That's open to anybody. It's a publicly available Grand Rounds.
This is Captain Heard, and we can very much appreciate looking forward to your work in this area.
Thank you. Thank you. And again,